[Music]
hi there internet
i'm john oliver host of last week
tonight we're off this week but much
like your fun aunt
i just can't seem to stop myself from
posting on the internet
and the reason i wanted to speak to you
was to discuss denmark the country known
for lego you know
choking hazards with brand sponsorships
specifically i'd like to talk about
children's television in denmark because
since the beginning of this year
there has been a new show there that's
got a lot of attention
denmark's flagship broadcaster has just
introduced a new children's show called
john dillerman that's essentially an
animation about a man with a huge
and uncontrollable penis this man has a
penis so massive and flexible can save
children from danger
fetch objects from a river and even
operate as a
pogo stick yeah it's true
denmark has a kids show called john
delaman about a claymation super mario
who's dressed for a ski vacation and a
1920s beach party at the same time
and who much more importantly has a
massive stripey snake dick
so i think now you can see why i wanted
to talk to you so badly
the dealer in is danish slang for penis
meaning that his name in english
is basically john penis man which is a
perfect name for a man with a magical
dong it would actually be
a great nickname for my own penis if i
hadn't already nicknamed it
hugh grant because it's british aging
and i've been told it can be unpleasant
to work with
and you should know it turns out john
dealerman can do nearly
anything with his appendage in his show
he uses it to
walk some dogs as you can see here he
also uses it as a tightrope in a circus
act
and to decorate a christmas tree in
spectacular fashion
and in one unforgettable episode he even
gets suspended from balloons by his
penis which is both completely
terrifying and also
how i assume cirque du soleil performers
commute to work
the show started airing in january and
was an instant hit
with the first episode being fused by
more than 250
000 children in just five days and i've
got to say
it's so much more imaginative than what
passes for children's entertainment here
because think about it
what do we have a fascist puppy police
state
evangelical vegetables a monkey who
plagiarized his only personality trait
from cats
and an eight-year-old aardvark who
dresses like alan alder
none of these characters can hold a
candle to john dealerman because
i guarantee none of them have ever saved
a group of drowning children
by using the centrifugal force of their
cartoonishly long schlong
you think barney the dinosaur could do
that of course not
he'd probably just sing a song about
friendship as though children sank into
the waves
do something barney
and while you've already seen some of
the footage inside it
i do want to make sure that you also
hear some of the show's theme songs
i mean musically that's excellent but
what you might be missing there is
just how good the lyrics are it's been
translated as hello
i am john johnson he has the world's
longest johnson
there's almost nothing he can't do with
it he can swing it around
he can get a bit embarrassed he could
save the whole world if only he had the
chance
come on that's profound
and the fascinating thing is the john
deereman is not really an
outlier in danish kids tv danish culture
routinely addresses topics with children
that the us
might think of as completely off limits
on danish public tv there are kids
programs that include
a puppet coming to terms with their
gender identity a pirate who tries to
join a satanic cult
and instead of the network going black
at night it plays a sleep-themed loop
of humans and puppets snoring and
farting at random intervals which is not
only
incredible television it's also a truly
fantastic sleep aid
rainforest sounds uh no thank you i'll
take unpredictable danish puppet farts
any day and dr the public broadcaster
behind this show maintains that john
dealerman
is genuinely wholesome saying it's about
the embarrassment
and fun of the body and that it was made
with the help of a non-profit
reproductive health organization
and a child psychologist in fact as the
head of dr's children's department made
clear
it's as desexualized as it can possibly
get
the problem is there are some both in
but especially outside denmark
who can't seem to get their head around
the charms of
this show watch as a danish expert gets
grilled by a british morning host
from your opinion uh making the uh
making this bit
enormous penis in fact a bit of a hero
good idea yeah well i
i don't think as ula also says i don't
think you should think of this as a
penis this is not a penis as we think of
it as an adult
uh this is this is isn't it coming out
of his knee why isn't it coming out of
his chest why is it coming out of there
yeah well well of course it is it is a
penis as such but it's not
it's not a sexualized penis it's the
piece that
a a young child has 20 foot long and
striped
it's not the penis that everybody has
well hold on there
because you don't know that that is not
the penis that everyone has and that
actually brings us to the reason i
wanted to talk to you about this show
because
the reason john dealerman resonated so
much with me isn't
just that i found it interesting or
charming or funny
is that i too happen to have a 20 foot
long animated hose dong
as you can see he has a suit and glasses
just like me
and for people like myself john deeleman
is the representation on television that
we've been looking for for a long time
because for us our penises aren't
necessarily
sexual are they no they're
multi-talented look
he can wiggle he can show off his
muscles
he can even make penis animals oh a
giraffe
fancy boy and he can become a limp worm
which
i will admit is well within the
wheelhouse of most penises of course
unfortunately
i can't keep him out for long because if
he inadvertently gets excited
he siphons off about a gallon of my
blood so back you go before i collapse
okay
[Music]
there we go and that's it that's really
all i wanted to tell you that and the
fact that we'll be back july 25th hey
discovery
you're gonna own this soon congrats on
the merger it's gonna go great
goodbye
you